now you've probably heard this phrase
flattening the curve when it comes to
this pandemic but what does that mean in
practice let me show you a few charts
that kind of explain it because the key
thing here is just looking at the rates
at how fast people are dying around the
world different countries facing
different forms of crises at the moment
you get a sense of this looking at this
chart it measures how fast the number of
people here in the in various different
countries are dying so the steeper the
curve the more people are dying more
quickly and the flat of the curve the
less quickly they are dying so you can
see South Korea over there they have
been seen as having managed this disease
far better than many countries in Europe
and almost all of Europe including it
should be said Germany and Sweden are in
the pack there and have a look at the UK
so we've just had confirmed 3605 deaths
in the UK but when you just look at a
few of these lines let's have a look at
the kind of extremes here so we'll take
South Korea at the bottom and then
you've got Spain and Italy which are
seen as being the epicenters of this
disease at the moment let's have a look
at where the UK and the US sit within
this you can see the UK and the US this
is the first 10 days after they passed a
hundred deaths so the first 10 days both
of those lines were actually below Italy
and Spain's lines it looked like they
were flatter than than those lines so
that was potentially an encouraging
source of news but it's what's happened
more recently that is causing concern
here in the UK and indeed in the u.s.
because both the UK line and the US
lines are getting steeper where as you
can see those lines for Spain and Italy
are actually getting flatter and the
upshot of this is the UK may well
overtake Italy the u.s. may overtake
Spain to become the biggest epicenter of
covert 19 in terms of the severity the
speed at which it is killing people and
right now the UK if it continues in its
current trajectory could well have
10,000 deaths in total by next week
that's how serious this is
that's why it matters to try and flatten
those curves and the reality I'm afraid
is what we're seeing on this chart is in
a way us looking through the rearview
mirror because a lot of these people who
have died in the last few days would
have contracted the disease some
weeks ago so there were big question
marks over how comparable these numbers
are but there is another question is it
that they are overstating the number of
people who are dying or is it that they
are understating it and there's if you
look at some of the figures as we have
done you get a particular picture so
this shows you those official numbers so
it's the equivalent of those official
numbers it's not a logarithmic chart
it's not a growth chart is an absolute
one so it's a slightly different shape
but that's the number of people number
of deaths that have been announced now
let's have a look when those people
actually died and it is a slightly
different picture you can see the date
of death curve is before they are
announced in other words we may now be
facing a more severe crisis but we'll
only hear about it in potentially a few
days or indeed a week or so as time that
is concerning and so too is the fact
that we don't really have a
comprehensive picture of how many people
are dying in total this shows you the
number of people who have died of all
causes in the UK that blue area there of
all causes in the UK each week since the
start of the year and you can see the
dotted line is the average of how many
people tend to die in each week and so
far it doesn't look like the UK's kind
of number of deaths is actually getting
above the average so that's quite
encouraging and in Italy in Spain this
blue area their equivalent of the blue
area is going far above the average so
you're having excess deaths as they
caused it call it bit his here's the
concern these numbers are slightly out
of days so we don't get them until the
lag of two weeks or so so we'll be
keeping a close eye on this chart some
people fear that that excess excess
death line could well rise above the
average over the course of the next few
weeks others say we have been over
counting those Cove at 19 deaths we will
have to keep a close eye on it because
there are lots of question marks about
the data but lots of concerns about
what's happening and lots of kind of
very clear clarity I think for many
people that we really need to try to
flatten those curves as quickly as
possible